(blues music)
- The cool thing about
Bilbo Walker is that
he grew up in the same Mississippi
Delta blues environment
as like Charley Patton, Robert
Johnson, or Muddy Waters,
or Howlin' Wolf or B.B. King.
And when he performs, it feels like that.
It is like a living fossil.
He's out there in the boonies,
not even a town, it's just out in a field.
And I also love the fact that
it's just so hard to find
right until you're at it.
It's an old army barracks,
Quonset hut cut in pieces,
moved onto this property himself.
Real authentic juke joint is
gonna be African-American owned
because it comes out of that culture
and it's probably gonna have
a big personality behind it.
Real juke joints that are
still operating with live music
I can probably count on one hand.
I used to say, “You're not gonna get
anymore juke joints like that.”
I would have to say Bilbo's
just gets grandfathered in.
It's just such a real thing
and it's kind of an extension of him
and sort of what he's
been doing his whole life.